vamos a continuar con nuestro estudio
del mercado de trabajo y en este vídeo
nos enfocaremos en la curva de demanda
de trabajo imaginemos que hablamos del
mercado de personas que trabajan para la
industria que produce pantalones digamos
que producen pantalones de campana aquí
hago un dibujo de los pantalones de
campana de alguien y digamos que por
alguna razón vuelven a estar de moda los
pantalones acampanados así que la
empresa a corto plazo obtiene más
ingreso por cada unidad de pantalón
acampanado aumenta el ingreso marginal y
si aumenta el ingreso marginal también
aumenta el ingreso marginal del producto
por lo que se desplazará a la derecha la
curva de ingreso marginal del producto o
podemos verlo como que se desplaza hacia
arriba para cierta cantidad de trabajo
se tiene un mayor ingreso marginal del
producto que llamamos curva marginal de
producto 2 que es lo que va a pasar en
el mercado pues si es una tendencia
general de moda que no solo aplica para
los bienes o productos de esta empresa
sino para todos los productores de
pantalones pues todos querrán a más
personas que trabajen en la industria de
producción de pantalones otra forma de
pensar
es que la curva de demanda del mercado
de trabajo va a ser una suma de las
curvas de ingreso marginal del producto
de todas las empresas y si las curvas de
todas las empresas se desplazaron hacia
la derecha o arriba lo mismo va a pasar
con la curva de demanda del mercado de
trabajo por lo que la curva ahora se ve
así es la curva de demanda del mercado
de trabajo sub 2 cómo afecta esto a la
cantidad de equilibrio y al salario de
equilibrio el salario de equilibrio sube
lo que es razonable porque la curva de
demanda se desplazó a la derecha y la
cantidad de equilibrio también aumentó
por la misma razón q sub 2 y que ocurre
con el costo marginal del factor para
las empresas que operan en este mercado
que ya contrataron este trabajo bueno el
salario aumentó por lo que también
aumentó el costo marginal del factor en
esta situación tenemos el costo marginal
del factor sub 2 ahora tenemos una nueva
cantidad de contratación que es racional
para esta empresa también podemos
imaginar que las cosas suceden al revés
en este ejemplo vimos que las curvas se
desplazan a la derecha tanto la curva
marginal del producto como la curva de
demanda del mercado de trabajo pero
quizás las cosas no van tan bien y
disminuye el ingreso marginal de estas
empresas ahora podemos imaginar una
situación en la que a nivel de la
empresa la curva de ingreso marginal del
producto se desplaza ahora abajo a la
izquierda quizá algo así curva de
ingreso marginal del producto sub 3 y
esto va a ocasionar que la curva de
demanda del mercado de trabajo también
se desplace a la izquierda curva de
demanda del mercado de trabajo sub 3
aquí vemos que ocurre lo opuesto hay un
salario de equilibrio menor y una menor
cantidad de equilibrio de trabajo en el
mercado todo esto ocasiona que disminuya
el costo marginal del factor cmg efe sub
3 suponiendo que tenemos un mercado de
trabajo en competencia perfecta y ahora
esta será la nueva cantidad de
equilibrio q sub 3 con asterisco
nuevamente esto suena lógico es algo que
hemos visto que ocurre en otros mercados
cuando hablamos de lo que ocasiona
desplazamientos en la demanda si por
alguna razón la siempre
no pueden tener ganancias adicionales
por cada unidad extra de trabajo esto va
a hacer que las cosas se desplacen a la
izquierda tanto a nivel de la empresa
como a nivel del mercado y si por alguna
razón las empresas pueden tener una
ganancia adicional por cada unidad extra
de trabajo esto va a desplazar a la
derecha tanto al ingreso marginal del
producto a nivel de la empresa como a la
curva de demanda del mercado laboral a
nivel del mercado